the ongoing nature of television series
means they tend to spawn more fan
theories and any other form of
entertainment
amid the ones that are absolutely
ridiculous are some that are actually
kind of plausible let's dive down the
rabbit hole and look at some crazy fan
theories that totally change these TV
shows Bikini Bottom nuclear wasteland in
one popular fan Theory Sponge Bob
Squarepants
Squidward Patrick and all the rest of
Bikini Bottom citizens were irradiated
during atomic tests turning them into
the bizarre characters we see today but
how that even happened well the
fictional Bikini Bottom is located on
the ocean floor under a place called
Bikini Atoll that name may sound
familiar because Bikini Atoll was
famously the site of 23 atomic bomb
tests in the 40s and 50s including some
underwater detonations these explosions
left the island and reef exposed to
massive amounts of radioactive fallout
and Bikini Atoll remains uninhabitable
to this day unless you live in a
pineapple a pineapple under the sea the
Paddy's Pub gang is way uglier than you
think this awesome theory about It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia comes to us
courtesy of a reddit thread from 2015 in
it a user going by the name Craig's
Benedict proposes that MACD and Dennis
are not really as attractive as they
appear to us viewers the idea relies on
the unreliable narrator premise in which
the story is told from the characters
narcissistic perspectives and it's not
how things actually are alright but you
get my point your honor and you could
see that Mac was slowing down at the end
there and let the record show that that
is because he only works out his glamour
mom oh that's that's book I did like
three more than you there's also some
evidence to back this up in the episode
high school reunion part two the gang
choreographs an amazing dance routine to
impress all the jerks who tease them in
high school
[Music]
of course what they are actually doing
is this if we take this theory seriously
it could explain why the rest of the
world treats these three attractive
people like total freaks well except for
the fact that they routinely act like
total freaks guys yummy cheese cheese
the fine I think she's a strange thing
uh I was wondering well what is she's
where is it guy professor Samurai Jack
in 1998 animator genndy tartakovsky was
a supervising producer on the Powerpuff
Girls for the Cartoon Network it follows
The Adventures of three super-powered
sisters who were created in a lab by a
guy named professor utonium actually
girls to him well you're pretty gross
yourselves with your big heads large
eyes little bodies then in 2001
Tartakovsky created another show called
Samurai Jack all about a warrior ripped
from the past and thrown into the future
who wage his battle against an immortal
demon named aku I am lost son the land
that you have pillaged I am here to
reclaim it for my people for my path or
my birthright throughout the series
Samurai Jack wanders around a dystopian
post-apocalyptic world and at one point
he makes his way to a ruined city that
looks kind of familiar because it sure
seems to resemble the city of townsville
from the Powerpuff Girls
not only that did you ever notice how
Jack kind of looks a whole lot like the
professor just what went wrong in
Townsville is this mojo jojo's fault
Asha's foreveryoung because of a magical
pokemon why is ash Ketcham the hero of
multiple Pokemon animated series always
ten years old through 19 seasons and
eighty movies he never ages
time definitely passes on the shows
because Ash spends weeks trekking
through the various regions on his quest
to collect badges and become a Pokemon
master
so by all accounts he should at least be
a teenager by now the answer may have
come in the very first episode of the
original series when Ash witnesses a
beautiful bird Pokemon flying into a
rainbow I still come I get to be
identified we later find out that this
was a legendary Pokemon called ho ho the
games say that anyone who sees hoo is
promised eternal happiness
and since Ash's fondest wishes to
forever travel the world collecting and
training Pokemon the ho ho granted this
wish giving ash eternal youth Sherlock
Holmes and Spock are related this is
probably the best theory on the list
since it might not simply be a theory at
least in the eyes of Star Trek fans
everywhere in Star Trek 6 the
undiscovered country spark who we must
remind you as half human must solve a
mystery in space and to do so he relies
on not only his Vulcan logic but his
human ancestry to an ancestor of mine
maintain that if you eliminate the
impossible whatever remains however
improbable must be the truth and that's
not the only time spark relies on the
wisdom of his forebears either are you
actually suggesting that from the few
issue eliminate the impossible whatever
remains however improbable must be the
truth how poetic
it's that quote a little familiar you
may be a fan of Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's
Sherlock Holmes novels the legendary
detective first utter the quote himself
in the 1890 story the sign of the for it
gets crazier in the modern BBC series
Sherlock Benedict Cumberbatch has set
the line himself as well as he
so whatever remains however improbable
must be true and then Sherlock and spark
finally met in 2013 kind of you are
suggesting the Admiral violated every
regulation he vowed to uphold simply
because he wanted to exploit your Intel
I wanted to exploit my savagery
my name is car it's a fly in the
ointment there all right Spock just take
it easy oh well maybe someday we'll get
this Sherlock star trek crossover we've
all been hoping for oh wait there can be
no argument the game is afoot
never mind thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
fan theories we should have added to the
list
[Music]